after lemonade comes beyonce's
renaissance
everything we know about her first new
album in six years
dress drama dividing the internet
after kim k's met gala look appears
damaged and pete makes his kardashians
debut sort of
she's probably seen my vagina
more than me
not more than you et's download starts
right now
beyonce fans it is time to get in
formation yes the most nominated woman
in grammy's history is officially
dropping a new album and here's
everything we know title tweeted the
news last night it's called renaissance
set for release on july 29th the record
is expected to have 16 tracks and you
can see it right there this is just act
one which means we could possibly get
more acts with more music it feels good
to know that the hard work paid off
on a scale of one to ten sided okay yeah
and here's the thing you as well as the
beehive knew that beyonce had something
cooking especially when she removed her
profile pictures from social media last
week and then eagle-eyed fans were also
quick to spot this pic posted beyonce's
charity account yesterday it shows a
finger pointing to brandy's b7 album and
of course beyonce historians know that
renaissance will be her seventh solo
album and that hand that you see right
here well get this google cannot find a
match for the image which has some fans
guessing could that be beyonce's
upcoming artwork
it's her first by the way since the
lemonade album and film which dropped in
2016 without any promo
another surprise be on the cover of the
july issue of british vogue today take a
look at this spread inside more clues to
what's coming the editor-in-chief who's
gotten early access to her new music is
already calling it music that makes you
rise music that will unite so many on
the dance floor music that touches your
soul and i cannot wait oh gosh
as for why it took beyonce so long even
though like i'm not complaining at all
i'm just patient the mag says that the
pandemic gave her time to think and
rethink every decision just the way she
likes it they say good things take time
that's exactly right all right now to
the season finale of the kardashians and
the cameo we have all been waiting for
so we here not see pete davidson in a
tmi nsfw but also hilarious moment with
kim and a producer pete come here you
have to meet paxy she's probably seen my
vagina
more than me
not more than you oh but wait there is
more pete talk oh my gosh are you in
pete besties
oh good punk beds whole thing oh my god
i think it's
really drama free everyone wants that
fairy tale ever including chloe herself
who is officially done so and moving on
from tristan thompson after another
cheating scandal did tristan have every
opportunity to tell me yes was tristan
going to tell me if there wasn't a baby
involved absolutely not the entire thing
is despicable well something delightful
holiday cheer from kris jenner dashing
through the snow
on a one-horse open sleigh
for the fields we go
laughing all the way
give the grammy her grammy
but let's circle back to kim though
she's accused of being a dress wrecker
some new photos are making the rounds
claiming kim stretched marilyn monroe's
iconic 1962 dress to the point of
tearing when she wore it to the met gala
last month kim's also being blamed for
ripping a shoulder strap and losing some
crystals but of course there are two
sides to every story a resurfaced video
from ripley's believe it or not the
company that loaned kim the 4.8 million
gown shows that the damage might have
already been there
[Music]
no
so now ripley's is taking it a step
further releasing a statement today
saying kim did not damage the garment in
the short amount of time she wore it a
report written in 2017 actually states a
number of the seams are pulled and worn
also there is puckering at the back by
the hooks and eyes really we should
blame jfk but that's another story all
right the internet is still taking sides
okay one person tweets kim completely
ruined the dress look at the effing
jewels torn off i just can't i gotta log
off for my blood pressure and the st
hoax vlog spoofs kim wearing the dress
after being told to handle with care
meanwhile a supporter writes kim
kardashian can't even walk a certain way
without someone complaining about it
well there are a few gowns she should
walk away from kim better not even think
about this dress as blowing up on
twitter with fans pleading to protect
pop culture relics like the infamous
paperback dress from rupaul's drag race
britney's denim look from 2001 bjork's
swan dress and gaga's meat dress oh and
this one is a definite no-no too which
what color is it anyway we are not we
are not still having this conversation
it's white and gold
speaking of marilyn her fascinating life
is being reimagined in the netflix drama
blonde premiering september 23rd now
here's your first look
please come
[Music]
[Music]
plays the legendary actress who died at
36. netflix says it will blur the lines
of fact and fiction reimagining
maryland's complicated life marilyn's
looks were iconic and so is the mustache
miles teller was rocking in top gun
maverick now miles is trading that stash
for another style in his new movie
looking really really good you are
rocking what could be an iconic
hairstyle again
okay
facial hair hairstyles was that your
idea your inspiration i mean it's a
choice i guess people let you know if it
becomes iconic i'll tell you my wife is
not a fan of either the mullet or the
mustache
miles and wife kelly turned his premiere
into an adorable date night she's
beautiful
she's all mine
time to worry about crossing lines was a
lot of lines ago
in spider head which drops tomorrow on
netflix miles's love interest is journey
smallette who was red hot last night in
this daring backless ruby cutout dress
and ready for her moment
are you hoping to be taking over that
number one coveted spot on netflix with
spider head i mean from your lips to
god's ears let's see
two number ones at the same time yeah
that'd be all right i would i would take
that
my dad believed in you the audience is
never wrong that's what something tom
really impressed upon me hey joe miss ya
miles re-teamed with maverick's director
joseph kozinski for spider-head after
their box office success
[Music]
what was tom cruise's reaction to the
turnout for top gun map he's so thrilled
and so happy and i think my like myself
relieved
[Music]
wait is zendaya pregnant i'm gonna stop
you right there the answer is no that's
actually a viral prank making the rounds
on tick tock viewers watch a fake story
then kris jenner pops up proven it's all
a joke i can't with the internet and
neither can zendaya who got wrapped up
in the trend on wednesday and shut the
rumors down real quick writing on her
instagram story this is why i stay off
twitter just making stuff up for no
reason still the prank had many
followers fooled including lilna's ex he
said i hate twitter because i'm sitting
here about to congratulate zendaya about
a baby that doesn't exist we also have
to assume tom holland's socials blew up
yesterday as well i mean the spiderman
co-stars have been famously private
about their romance but if the time does
come
no who knows
the world may never know
meanwhile selena gomez is lifting the
lid on her high-profile breakup from
justin
to lose bieber to love me
on the hollywood reporters awards
chatter podcast selena got real about
splitting up in the spotlight it was
necessary for me to walk through those
things
um
i had a lot of soul-searching to do
selena and justin called it quits for
good in 2018. now she's looking back on
lessons learned it allowed me to develop
such a character
where i don't tolerate any sort of
nonsense or respect in any way
and i think i'm really proud of how i've
come out of it
she has come out of it and she is
keeping busy with a handful of projects
she says new music is on the way too and
of course she just finished shooting
season two of her hit show only murders
in the building with steve martin and
martin short our lives blow up but we
all go down for this
don't you want to clear your name too i
have to see this thoroughly what can we
expect this time around what murderer
can we expect more crime more murder
pervious this is really funny yes
we can't tell you anything no it's
honestly gonna be great we want wanted
to be the best one
well another show we're getting more of
hacks was just green lit for a third
season on hbo max the season two finale
this month saw jean smart's debra vance
fire co-writer ava played by hannah
einbinder so ava can make space for her
own career and the cast already has some
ideas up their sleeves for what's ahead
where does debra go from here i have
such faith in the writers that they'll
take her where we all want to see her go
which is up up and away what is one
question you would want answered in
season three
um
will ava get bangs
stay tuned to find out
also returning to the small screen the
infamous a stirring up new trouble for a
new generation of liars
[Music]
hbo max just released this chilling
first look at pretty little liar's
original sin which premieres july 28th
the show's creators say the new high
school clique will pay for the secret
sins their parents committed two decades
ago one secret we can't keep og pll star
lucy hale telling e.t she's already a
fan of the new cast and the feeling is
mutual
i know one sweet angel on that show her
name's bailey madison and i love her hi
bailey i mean i grew up the biggest fan
of the original pll uh i was a for
halloween you know i i've grown up
admiring the girls
and their support has met the world
moving on to our tom brady exclusive yes
we know tom's the greatest of all time
on the field but at home et's kevin
frazier found out tom's just a husband
whose wife takes videos of him in his
underwear
can we talk about you breaking the
internet
somebody's
anyone though
there you are in your underwear it was
just a fun moment i'm glad it was her
catching me in my underwear and not
anyone else let me say that
let me see
shout out to wife of 13 years giselle
for curating that viral brady and his
briefs ambush which showed off the very
fit 44 year old quarterback i looked at
that and i was like damn what are you
doing man what are you doing i'm working
hard at it kev this is a pro football
player's body i'm trying to stay in
shape with these young 25 year olds it's
a commitment
brady is gearing up to join his fellow
buccaneers for training camp next month
after announcing his retirement then
nearly six weeks later changing his mind
i'm not leaving
and that's at the center of his new
let's go campaign with hertz what did
you think when hertz came to you and
they said they want to play off your
retirement you know just thought we'd
have some fun around it i mean life is
super serious these days maybe all you
needed
was a vacation did you just need a
vacation is that what brought you back
there was a little more than that it's
tough to make a decision right at the
end of the season i needed time and i
just figured i'm gonna go at it again
for now the seven-time super bowl champ
is all about spending time with his mvps
gisele and his kids fourteen-year-old
john who he shares with ex bridget
moynihan and his two with gisele
twelve-year-old benjamin and
nine-year-old vivian who crashed our
interviews somebody just got home
my little girl
here she goes
sorry about that kev oh it's great it's
your last day of school i got three
amazing kids my wife's so supportive and
she holds it down during the season you
know i'm very very blessed
and speaking of kids brian austin green
and sharna burgess are schooling us on
how they make their blended family work
they're expecting their first baby
together and charner told the vile files
that when their relationship got serious
she checked in with brian's ex-wife
megan fox after we'd been dating for
about was it five months four or five
months when i asked i was like can i get
megan's number i'd love to text oh yeah
and say hey i'm around your kids all the
time if you ever want to know anything
about me or if you ever want to get
coffee let me know and she's she's
thanked me for being great with her kids
too
brian and megan finalized their divorce
back in february but says he doesn't
regret a thing
it's a 15-year relationship we have
three beautiful kids
so
it was really amazing at the end of the
day
a source tells e.t that megan is cordial
with brian and sharna but she's living
her own life and focused on her
relationship with mgk you know someone
who also knows a thing or two about
co-parenting hayden christensen he
shares a seven-year-old daughter with
jumper co-star rachel bilson and tells
e.t his little one makes the perfect
sparring partner yeah she was my first
lifesaver training partner when i
started on this we were in the house you
know
clashing lightsabers
hayden recently made his return to the
star wars universe in the new disney
plus series obi-wan kenobi where he
reunites with his former co-star and
close friend ewan mcgregor
getting to come back and
and work with him again has been amazing
i love hayden it felt like
you know there's special people in your
life as you go along
your life and he's one of those to me
also feeling the love and nostalgia is
the cast of the father of the bride
remake which premieres today on hbo max
et's nichelle turner got to catch up
with gloria stefan who talks her special
connection to co-star andy garcia
show time baby
andy was the first other the only other
man you've ever kissed besides amelia
you know i was watching for it will this
be the first time emilio sees it tonight
okay he's still already seen it although
i banished him when we were gonna shoot
it but no it was i mean it wasn't me
kissing andy it was ingrid kissing billy
so that's a different thing there's a
lot of new elements in it you both have
been coming here for over a year do you
still want this marriage to work or not
i'm here no gloria and andy definitely
put a fun latin american twist on the
classic i'm engaged
and i propose does anyone do that what
do you remember about that day that
emilio asked you to marry him oh my god
what do i remember that he never asked
me to marry him what uh all he did is
hand me a little box his mother sat
behind me
and i'm going this is weird and it
opened the box and there was a ring he
never said a word i didn't know whether
to kiss him or kiss his mom
what do you remember about when you
asked your wife to marry you about that
day
i i proposed to on the night i met her
at a club she said yes that night but
we've got married about five years later
so she's been putting up with me ever
since
poor unfortunate souls we've still got
another year before hearing melissa
mccarthy as ursula in disney's
live-action little mermaid she told
kelly clarkson this week she's still in
shock but i love that song and when you
finally recorded it and they're like
that's it you've got your song i
literally burst out crying
in the meantime though she is teaming up
again with her husband ben falcone in
the new netflix comedy god's favorite
idiot et's kevin frasier got the details
on that and melissa's new blonde
ambition
melissa do blondes have more fun
they really do come on i loved
everything about amelie it's boozing
pills and never saying quite the right
thing maybe you're gonna spontaneously
combust maybe what blow low percentage
ben and melissa have starred together 20
times their newest is kind of a new spin
on bruce almighty in god's favorite
idiot a new eight-episode netflix comedy
the two play co-workers who fall in love
it kind of harken back to some of those
moments you know doing bridesmaids of
course things get complicated when ben
gets struck by lightning turns out he's
been chosen to be god's messenger to
save the world melissa if you had that
power what would you go out and fix and
heal just
don't judge let people live their lives
and lead with kindness
well there is nothing kind about emma
thompson's next role oh there is not the
oscar-winning actress is unrecognizable
in the first trailer for roald dahl's
matilda the musical this school
is full of rebels
transforms into the infamous head
mistress miss trunchbull in the
adaptation out on netflix this holiday
season
[Music]
see if that child is still alive
we've also got our eyes on the final
episodes of better call saul the series
returns to amc july 11. et's matt cohen
spoke with brian cranston about reviving
walter white we're done
when i say we're done you're gonna go
back and play walter on better call saul
with aaron it's kind of a challenge
until you show up and they have your
wardrobe that you go oh look at that
yeah i remember these shoes say my name
but before the breaking bad reunion you
can catch brian as a far less nefarious
but just as clever mathematician who
along with his wife played by annette
benning breaks the lottery in jerry and
marge go large out june 17th on
paramount plus i found this flaw there's
a loophole that the lottery didn't see
it's right here in the map oh and this
is a true story that's what i love so
much about the story is that they
weren't cheating or scamming they played
it honestly and
action
e.t has the exclusive look behind the
scenes as annette and brian transform
into larry and marge selby the real-life
couple who discovered a loophole to win
27 million over the course of nine years
we're professional lottery players that
isn't a thing it is now when was the
last time you two played the lottery i
have never played the law really i have
never played the lottery ever not once
she's a virgin so be gentle
coming up chrissy teigen reveals her
son's celebrity bff he has no idea like
how cool these people are
and keith urban on his special pre-show
ritual with wife nicole kidman each of
the downloads we'll be right back
[Music]
i've always had it in my head that you
and john would make an amazing couple i
started realizing like very slowly
that he really loves your movies it's
our running joke i was like i'm going on
james today and and guess who's gonna be
there your girlfriend
chrissy teigen is revealing two roseburn
this week her hubby john legend has a
crush and she's not the only person
stealing hearts chrissy spoke
exclusively with e.t about her son's
celebrity bromance
miles was like growing out with her
childhood crush lance bass who knew is
he ready to be in a boy band now i mean
oh he has no idea like how cool these
people are who's one of celebrity crush
luna loves whitney cummings so like they
play with makeup together is there one
celebrity in particular that you would
be incredibly afraid to face in your
courtroom honestly big celebrities just
like scare the crap out of me no way i
don't believe it that's why i used to
say that like that's why i used to drink
a lot for award shows and stuff and i'm
like a little scared facing everybody
like head-on robby do you have any
evidence of this i have tons of evidence
what can you tease for us for season two
it's not even mom and i that bring
the most joy on the show it's all of our
it's it's the plain tips i mean they do
they really are quite funny what do you
got over there i go hope i go home
i have a little game i'd like to play
with you sustained or overruled so i'll
give you quick scenarios you tell me
sustain so basically you allow it
overworld rejected okay luna wants to
get her belly button here overrule
totally yes
miles wants to follow in bad singing
footsteps that's sustained but that is
substance that's not gonna happen if
anything i can see him being um a dancer
john wants to renew your wedding vows
yeah i'd allow it every everything goes
back to housewives and it's sometimes
like the kiss of death right yeah i
would like it i would like it
[Music]
so john legends headed out on a european
tour soon and keith urban is giving et's
rachel smith some exclusive scoop about
his own upcoming shows including how he
gets ready with his musical muse
[Music]
do you do a certain like vocal warm-up
you did just post a video on the gram
are you serenading nicole i don't know
if that's a serenade
[Music]
is that how you normally warm up for a
show if nicole's around no no
you're just feeling it at the moment
yeah i'm i'm pretty loose
honestly
[Music]
this new music i've been working on i'm
very excited for people get to hear it
on friday keith's hitting the road again
for the u.s leg of the speed up now
world tour playing 50 shows across the
country and even though it runs nearly
five months he's still making time for
wife nicole kidman and their daughters
sunday in faith i'm lucky where i can do
a few shows and then come home for a few
days it also keeps the shows
fresh guess i love the way it hurts
i forgot an exact number 542
days between the last gig in 2020 and
the first one
what at the end of 21 or something was
crazy i've never not played that long
since i was
12 years old 13 years old how has that
felt terrible
[Music]
you know just like keith we're hitting
the road too
tune in tomorrow for a special episode
of et's the download highlighting black
icons in music who have inspired movie
magic oh you don't want to miss it until
then we'll let mr urban play us out bye
everyone
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]